justo en el momento de las
conversaciones para reactivar el acuerdo
nuclear con irán el organismo
internacional de energía atómica anunció
que teherán comenzó a enriquecer uranio
hasta en un 20 por ciento de pureza y a
utilizar centrifugadoras más avanzadas
para ello esto en su planta de fordo en
lo profundo de una montaña cerca de la
ciudad de qom irán ha restado
importancia al informe pero el director
de la hoya dijo que los acontecimientos
eran preocupantes en declaraciones a
france 24 granjas de chicle obstante
irán tiene este nivel de ambición en
términos de las nuevas actividades
nucleares que están llevando a cabo y
por las que deberían autorizar el acceso
completo a mis inspectores si limitan
este acceso entonces tenemos un problema
si es del wyndham drone
irán a estado restringiendo a la olla la
inspección de sus instalaciones
nucleares utilizando
efectivamente las inspecciones como
moneda de cambio según los analistas con
el fin de ganar más influencia el
abandono gradual por parte de irán de
sus compromisos del acuerdo de 2015 ha
despertado alarma entre los países
occidentales
ejerciendo presión para que se levanten
a las sanciones según el acuerdo irán
tenían limitado el nivel de
enriquecimiento de uranio al 36 % pero
ahora lo está haciendo a niveles mucho
más altos del 20 al 60 por ciento aunque
no llega al 90 por ciento necesario para
un arma nuclear en viena los
negociadores iraníes exigen un alivio de
las sanciones de eeuu la unión europea y
la onu como condición para reactivar el
acuerdo que se vino abajo en 2018 cuando
el presidente estadounidense donald
trump decidió retirarse unilateralmente
por su parte irá mantiene que su
programa nuclear sólo tiene fines
civiles